darin ist eine gesellschaft ist das ein
graus oder eine schöne wunschvorstellung
wir haben vorhin schon so ein bisschen
ein disput darüber
sie haben schon gesagt das wäre für sie
auch nicht das ziel gleichzeitig sind
sie eine person die die abgründe der
rauschzustände auch kennengelernt hat ja
ich denke eine eine rauschfrei
gesellschaft ist nicht anzustreben
es würde von menschen bild ausgehen dass
absoluter in der realität wie man sie
hat erlebt wie man sie sieht vorbei geht
und es würde zu zwängen führen das würde
war für mich eine keine wirklich gute
vorstellung
jetzt bei den verboten hat man ja schon
gewisse erfahrung gemacht in den usa in
der prohibition in den 90ern in zürich
mit der sehr streng dass dem sehr
strengen verbot von heroin das überhaupt
nichts genutzt hat
man muss raus wirklich wie ein trieb
verstehen das ist nicht etwas dass das
einfach verschwinden wird weil es wird
weil wir es nicht gut finden
ich habe die diskussion zwischen der
individuellen und der gesellschaft ebene
sehr spannend gefunden weil da sich die
frage stellt wie viel raus braucht eine
gesellschaft also wie oft muss ich meine
verantwortung abgeben können loslassen
können entspannen können um den rest der
zeit quasi diese verantwortung tragen zu
können
und für mich war der rausch nicht immer
aber oft der punkt an dem ich entspannen
oder loslassen konnte damit ich danach
wieder bereit war meine leistung zu
erbringen
mit der zeit habe ich verpasst wie
entspannung und für die leistung meine
meine substanzen
aber grundsätzlich denke ich wenn die
möglichkeit zum schnellen entspannen
oder zum schnellen genießen
weggenommen wird und man für alles drei
wochen ferien machen muss um die gleiche
entspannung zu erreichen wie man nach
ein paar gläsern wein und einem guten
gespräch
das wäre nicht für mich nicht
anzustreben
ich glaube wir sehen die ganze zeit
schon die unterschiedliche zwecke einen
rauschzustand verfolgen kann also die
entspannung dazwischen aber auch das
totale aus sich heraus brechen die
ekstase die bewusstseinserweiterung so
viele substanzen so viele
unterschiedliche ziele
mich würde aber trotzdem noch
interessieren die wir eigentlich auf die
realität blicken pedro lenz hat freuen
das schöne bild gebracht die realität
ist so fade wie ein magerquark ich so
schlimm
reicht ihnen der magerquark ist eine
sehr gute frage
ich empfinde meine meine realität
tatsächlich gar nicht jetzt magerquark
aber und muss ihr oder will er deshalb
auch gar nicht häufig entfliehen
ich habe mir ein bisschen eher das
gefühl dass wir in zeiten leben die sehr
rasant sich gerade verändern und dass
viele menschen damit auch mit sorgen und
angst reagieren und natürlich dann die
versuchung nahe liegt diese sorgen diese
angst zu wegzumachen weg zu rauschen zu
sagen oder davon zu rauschen oder der
französischen genau und ich habe dann
das gefühl möchte ich eigentlich in
einer gesellschaft leben die die
wegschaut
die bewusst die ganze zeit wegschaut ich
habe ohnehin das gefühl unsere
elektronischen unterhalter die wir eben
immer bei uns tragen tragen schon stark
dazu bei dass wir sehr viel uns nicht
mehr mit der realität beschäftigen und
wenn das weiter verstärkt wird durch
substanzen dann werden wir uns
vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr dann
verändern wir vielleicht diese welt gar
nicht mehr so wie sie es braucht damit
wir weiterhin ihn erleben können so
dauerhaft schon ein bisschen aus hatten
aber auch ein bisschen unter der vor
allem den schmerz der schmerz ist zu was
gut und den schmerz immer weg machen das
ist schlecht
wir müssen was verändern wenn es wehtut
das haben wir ganz ganz viel durch den
kopf also erst mal wollte ich sagen dass
ich innerlich herbert sehr zugestimmt
habe weil ich tatsächlich auch sehr auf
die mündigkeit des menschen setze und
glaube dass man durch gesellschaftliche
verbote eher das gegenteil erreicht also
weil ich glaube dass tatsächlich das
verbot und der exzess sind eigentlich
zwei seiten ein und derselben medaille
je mehr ich verbiete desto größer wird
die lust an der grenzüberschreitung und
der exzess und je mehr ich irgendwie die
die die liste oder die das bedürfnis
irgendwie nach grenzüberschreitung
unterdrücke dass grasser wird der
ausbruch seien
und dann wollte ich nur mal sagen zum
magerquark ich finde man muss das finde
ich schon sehen dass einfach die
menschliche existenz der eine ist die
nicht so einfach ist
also wir wissen dass wir sterben werden
wir stellen uns die sinnfrage warum sind
wir überhaupt auf der welt
also es ist eigentlich eine eine
existenz mit wahnsinnig vielen fragen
und unsicherheiten verbunden ist und ich
finde es dann ehrlich gesagt okay dass
man hin und wieder den rausch aussucht
und ich würde schon sagen dass das zur
menschlichen existenz wirklich auch dazu
gehört genauso wieder also dieser
überschuss genauso wie auch das
bedürfnis nach schönheit nach kunst nach
nach so vielen dingen die wir eigentlich
nicht im wirklichen sinne brauchen um zu
leben was irgendwie hinausgeht über über
wasser und brot aber genau wir brauchen
es zum trieb war vorhin die rede aber
dann müsste man es gar nicht so
darstellen als wäre es ein therapeutikum
das hätte es den zweck das bewusstsein
zu erweitern sondern ist einfach der
ausstieg herscheid naja ich glaube nicht
dass es sinn macht quasi diese
rauschzustände zu nutzen um eben zu
fliehen
ich sehe ein bisschen das risiko darin
dass sie als enorme intensitäten in sich
tragen und durch diese starke intensität
letztlich den blick
auf die alltagsrealität auch ein
stückweit verzehren so ich denke das
bewusstsein nicht so skalierbar ähnlich
wie ein mikroskop oder je weiter wir
heraus zoomen oder umso stärker wir uns
in intensitäten gegeben und so weniger
erkennen wir eigentlich wie berauschend
auch die alltagsrealität sein kann wie
viel schönheit wie viel besonderheit
letztlich auch in den alltäglichen
dingen drinsteckt und kann das ist jetzt
überraschend für mich von ihnen die sie
ja eigentlich plädieren dafür diese
substanzen zumindest sind kontrollierten
studien schon mal zuzulassen sie sagen
jetzt wenn er das so oft tun dann
verlieren wir den sinn für das
rauschhafte im auto
ich sehe auch die gefahr oder dass die
intensitäten des rausches letztlich auch
eine lehre und eine lange weile
hinterlassen können oder dass menschen
die in der lehre oder langeweile drin
sind sich cars in diese intensitäten
hinein flüchten und psychiatrisch
psychotherapeutischen sich denkt das ist
nicht der sinn des rausches sondern der
sinn des rausches soll seien letztlich
ein stück weit das besondere im
täglichen leben wieder zu erkennen und
wertzuschätzen und auch an unseren
realen beziehungen letztlich zu können
sie nur noch ganz kurz das gerne
verstehen möchte nur ein beispiel geben
sie gehen auf lsd trip keine ahnung sie
haben 1000 blumen und sterne und die
welt umarmt sie und so weiter was genau
lernen sie jetzt für den alltag die
schönheit quasi in den alltäglichen
dingen zu sehen wenn ich in der natur
draußen bin beispielsweise die blüten
einer blume wertzuschätzen als ein
symbol oder für das leben und es schärft
mir quasi den blick
wie der lebensprozesse manifestiert und
in welchen formen mit sich selbst
kommuniziert ich finde wir müssen
vielleicht nochmal genauer gucken
welcher rausch ist denn in ordnung also
was gibt es denn für rausch formen wo
man wo man sich darauf einigen kann das
ist okay ist oder anders gefragt
an welchen punkten macht es unsere
heutige gesellschaft schwer genau diese
formen des rausches auch zu leben und
was mir vorhin zum beispiel bei dieser
statistik ein viel das ist jetzt noch
nicht raus aber dieses wer trinkt jeden
tag alkohol wer ist abhängig und die
grenzen der abhängigkeit oder sagen wir
mal das pathologische alkoholgenusses
die werden ja immer enger gezogen
also ich hab mal irgendwo gelesen jemand
der jeden tag ein glas bier trinkt ist
eigentlich quasi schon abhängig weil er
ja jeden tag ein glas bier trinkt ich
bin eine sehr überzeugte feierabendbier
trinkerin ich trinke jeden abend ein
bier- und das lasse ich mir auch nicht
nehmen dieses bier will ich trinken und
mir hilft das irgendwie in diesen in
diesen feierabend hinüber zu wechseln
der zweite punkt ist ich finde es gibt
zwei formen des rausches jetzt im
engeren sinne
die ich sehr befürworte der einen rausch
das ist der eigentlichen rausch der der
sich um verfügbar ein stellt er sich
zufällig einstellt ich glaube dass wir
heute ja in einer kultur leben wo wir
selbst den rausch sehr genau planen
wollen ja durch was ich google map
irgendwelche daten
man verabredet sich es muss alles
irgendwie stimmen dazu gehört wenn ich
auch das micro dosen also man ist das
ist alles genau geplant und so weiter
aber der tollste rausch ist doch der wo
man eigentlich nichts erwartet und
plötzlich wird es grandios einfach mit
anderen und das dritte das dritte moment
ist eigentlich der wirklich innere auch
in rituale eingefasste rausch also
karneval
bei mir war es das schützenfest sowohl
leute einfach vier tage zusammen sind
und es ist es gelten ganz andere dass
sie eigentlich beim ritualisierten
rauschen das ist das beste stichwort um
zum nächsten thema zu kommen